[Music]
so yeah today I'm going to talk to you
about how I made a genetic algorithm
play risk so yeah let's go on with it
and do some risk analysis so I've
started to talk a bit like this way
first uh since I guess many of you have
played the game of risk but maybe not
all of you it might be it might be quite
a long time ago first I'll give you an
introduction to the game of Risk just to
very quickly go through the game then
I'll talk to you about how I implemented
risk in fighting and I show I'll show
you the code then I'll give you an
introduction to genetic algorithms and
finally I'll show you the results of
standard rate so about the game it was
invented quite a long time ago first
time we came out it was actually not
called risk but it was called the
conquest of the world in 1957 but
nowadays is always known as risk and
according to the publishers you can play
with two to six players I think it's
more fun with four or more and the
playing time is somewhere between one
and eight hours I can tell you if you
automate this this goes a lot quicker so
first of all the game board typically
there's many versions but typically it
looks a bit like this so there's what
you see here there's six continents each
of them have a different color and each
continent is divided into some countries
or regions whatever and so what what
happens when you set up the game first
you gather some players so for example
you gather four players and then you
randomly distribute all these regions
between the players so I've indicated
that the players here with different
colors and then every player puts one
army which is indicated by the one in
each of the circles here the app places
the one army on each of the region he
owns so then in the end there's at least
one army or in this case exactly one
army on every region there's and then
all the other players place a certain
number of
armies which depends on the number of
players on each of the regions such that
they all have quite a few of armies on
the game board this is when the game
actually starts so people have placed
the armies and now the game starts and
then so every player gets to play at
turn one by one and each turn consists
of three stages first is reinforcement
then there's combat and then there's
fortification so first in reinforcement
the player places some additional armies
so they already got some armies on the
board but they get a few more and so the
number of armies they get to place
depends on a number of factors so for
first they get one army for three
territories their own and then there's
some bonuses for owning a full continent
or having some set of reinforcement
cards which I'll not go into then in the
second stage they can use those new
armies to attack neighboring territories
so they can take a number of armies and
go into a neighboring territory and then
attack a neighbor the battle has decided
using dice and they're going to enter
into that but I can tell you that the
more armies you have the better your
chances and then so if you conquer the
territory than the territory will be
yours you will get a reinforcement card
and then where you can keep on attacking
until you've had enough or until you ran
out of armies and then in final stage
fortification people say you can use any
armies that are still on the board that
you haven't used up for attacking and
move them around to another character
you can do this only once you can you
take one region and move armies to a
neighboring region you can move as many
armies as you like but just between
those two regions so that's it this is
how the game is played the first well we
need to know how a player wins well that
at the beginning of the game each player
is assigned a mission and by completing
this mission the player wins missions
are well vary between things like
conquer after
guy in North America or any number of
continents destroy another player or
conquer at least 24 territories those
are these regions there's quite a few
more we'll get to this later so the game
of Risk I guess most of you sort of get
an idea what the game is about so let's
let's have a look at how this looks in
Python so I built the framework that
handles all these aspects of this game
and it consists of five classes so first
of all there's the board which handles
all the armies that are placed on the
game board then there's the cards which
handle the reinforcement cards of the
player then there's the mission which
describes the mission of the player and
there's the player itself which needs to
make decisions on how to play and then
finally there's a game which keeps track
of turns contains the board etc so let's
have a look at this first let's have a
look at the board so immediately when
initialized we have to tell it how many
players are there and then it randomly
distributes the territories amongst the
players so for example if I say B is
board that create a number of players is
4 then I get a board with 4 4 players
then I can plot the board using a method
called plot board very easy and then it
will show you exactly what the state of
the game is just like this and like I
said the region have already been
distributed among the players and one
army has been placed on average their
job
it's fairly easy to manipulate the
armies on the board so for example I can
just take any territory territory 0 and
say well this is now owned by player 5
and then set the number of armies on
that territory to 15 and then you see
they're right in the middle there is a
black territory owned by the black layer
containing 450 armies of course that
doesn't really make sense in a game with
4 players but but it's fairly easy to do
it that's what I want to show
then well the board is also aware of the
layout of the territories which makes it
easy to just parallel for example think
of all the attacks you can make so for
example if you just ask the board what
are the neighbors of territory zero then
we'll just tell you you get a list of
all the territories players and the
armies on that on those territories
around territory zero this means that it
can also and will attack moves using
this so for example then I can tell it I
won the want to attack from territory 0
to territory 21 with three attackers
and then you can see once you plot the
board that in this case it was actually
successful and you managed to take
another territory the board also rolls
the dice and just handles all that said
you don't have me to do all the dice for
elements figuring out whether one so
then there's missions so I made a
mission function that returns all the
missions for a given number of players
so then the missions actually depend on
the number of players because well like
you can see and at the bottom there's
also missions that say eliminate another
player and of course these players need
to be actually in the game for the
mission to be there so this these
missions you can get them using this
function and these missions are actually
aware of the player they are assigned to
so first of all if we just just take a
mission is the mission that says conquer
Asia in South America and then it's
unassigned and then we can assign it to
for example player zero and then it's
designed to read and then the mission
itself can evaluate whether it has been
achieved and you can just say okay
mission evaluate with the board this is
the board and it will return at the
beginning of the game it will return
false of course
then there's a special case of course
when a player is is to kill himself so
suppose we have the mission eliminate
the yellow player and then we assign
this to yellow then it turns into the
full-back mission conquered twenty-four
territories assigned to yellow so all of
this is handled inside the game you
don't have to care about it and then of
course well the most important part
there's a player object a player object
is required to have four method so
there's the reinforced method the attack
method fortify method and the turn
encouragement to the first three methods
handle the first three stages of the
game so the game takes the player object
then calls each of these method methods
when it's the this players turn to do
that do exactly that and then the player
object should return what they wants to
do the turning guards method has to do
with the reinforcement cars I'll not go
into that so now I've show you how what
what the classes look like let's go
through a whole game I've implemented
some random players which can play the
game but absolutely randomly so every
time it randomly decided decides what to
do and so let's see what happens so
first of all we create a game and we
take four random players we put it
inside the game and then let's show the
board here like you can see it may be a
bit difficult to see you there it shows
some statistics on the on the games on
the top left it says says pre game and
the bottom left is it shows which
players are in the game how many
territories and how many arguments they
have so then the first stage of the game
is to place the armies on the board so
first of all we can say game initialize
a single army and then every player
places a single army on the board you
can see that every for every player
there is at least there's exactly one
circle that has a two inside so
take place army now they can flex place
armies up until they each have 30 armies
on the board and maybe a little tedious
to call this thing 20 times so there's
also a method that says just initialize
armies and that handled all of it
so then this is a game board all players
have placed their armies and now it's
time for the first turn and Excise in
the top left turn zero red it also
mentions the mission of this player
namely it's eliminate the blue player
then but it's red stern first red can
reinforce if you look closely on to this
board you can see that red actually
placed three more armies on this board
and then the next stage is to attack and
here all that happened is I know I
realize it's very difficult to see if
you're not really into looking at the
game and watching what happens exactly
but what happened here is that red
attacked that territory there and yellow
lost one single army and then red
randomly decided to stop attacking and
then he can fortify and I think you're
actually 45 I don't know where but like
I said this is all red so it's just it
does anything that it can do it just
looks up a list of all the things that
you can do and picks one and then so
once that is done we call next turn it's
a turn of blue and then off this is the
state of the game so we can also use the
play turn method which just handles a
full turn so now this is what the board
looks like after blue and good step of
course we can we can keep doing this but
it gets a little tedious so let's speed
this up let's do this ten times we see
that red is doing prepare fairly well
and then we can just loop until the game
has ended and then we see that red has
indeed eliminated the blue player India
okay so that's again now let's get into
genetic algorithms so first what is the
genetic element it's the machine
learning algorithm based on evolution
and natural selection so why would I use
it well it's fairly easy to use with
little knowledge of the problem I know
the game but I don't know exactly how to
play it well and it's fairly reboost
against noise and having many dimensions
because of course there are very many
dimensions so first let's take a very
simple imagine we're trying to solve a
puzzle and the puzzle contains of the
solution of this puzzle is a is a 16-bit
string so for example the one I show
right here and what we can do to solve
this puzzle is we just are if we take a
candidate solution so any a string of 16
bits and then there is a function and
yeah a hypothetical function that tells
me exactly how many of the bits are
correct so in this example at the bottom
here this function would yield seven
telling me that seven of the bits are
correct of course this isn't a problem
that you can easily brute-force but
that's not the idea
so what we could do here is we could
just randomly generate a few solutions
in this case here there's four solutions
and if we apply this this function on
them we get a result so the top two have
nine bits correct in the bottom two I'm
much less good so of course we could
generate more until we get the right
answer or we can be smart about it and
combine the best solutions so we know
that there's two solutions that have
nine bits correct
I've shown I showed them here again and
I've made one red and the other blue
just for illustration purposes and then
we split these up and paste them
together to form children of these two
solutions so what that happens is also
first for example I take the first
eight bits of the blue one and then the
last eight bits of the red one and then
I get a solution that is much less good
than the other be original too but if I
take the first eight bits of the red one
and then the last eight bits of the blue
one I get a solution that is much better
so using this method we can take we can
take two solutions and create solutions
that might be better than the original
ones another way to improve any of these
solutions is to just randomly mutate it
so for example we could flip one of the
bits so if we take this solution that we
got before there was the best solution
we had and then wreden four times
randomly flip a bit that we get four
solutions that might be better or might
be worse in this case we get to better
solutions and two worst solutions and we
can keep doing this combining solutions
and then mutating them until we have
found the best solution and then in this
case of course the best solution is the
one where 16 bits are correct but then
you get in case of a game of Risk the
best solution please ma egg player that
always wins so in short the genetic
algorithm requires a random initial pool
of solutions of course if you have
already have a pool of solutions that
are better than random you can use these
some evaluation function a combined
method and a mutant need 8 method and
then you just need to look the combine
and a mutate until you're satisfied so
now let's think about a genetic
algorithm before how would you do this
um there's a little problem because like
in the example before we had these
solutions and we had an evaluation
function that tells us exactly how good
our solution is it says 9 or 6 or 12 and
then I know 12 is the best but of course
suppose we have 4 risk players player 1
through player 4 then which is the best
I cannot just I don't have an evil
evaluation function that tells me
exactly how good this players of course
we could have these players all these
four players play
game so we have four players we play one
game and play three wins
then it might well be that player three
is the best we can do this a few more
times and then we might see that in the
first time a player three was just lucky
so in the end maybe player one is even
better so this is doable if we have just
four players we can just have it play
eight times or something and then take
the player that won the most times is
the best player but what if we have
eight players we cannot have eight
players play a single game together
because the game only supports up to six
players of course we could have players
one through four play a single game and
then players five through eight play a
single game but then we would never know
whether player one is better than player
five because they never had any
interaction between now of course we
could play games with all combinations
but of course if you have a player pool
of Android players that would require
millions and millions of games and that
just doesn't work
luckily there's a solution the solution
is trueskill according to Wikipedia it's
a Bayesian ranking algorithm developed
by Microsoft and it's actually used in
the ranking of players of Xbox online
games so it works roughly like this and
I stole this from Vincent's blog so
suppose you have two new players then
you have one you create a prior your
prior knowledge of these players on a
scale from left to view very bad to
derive to play being very good then you
know nothing about them so they must be
somewhere in the middle
probably so your distribution of their
skill will be quite wide and centered in
the middle now suppose that player one
top player wins then it must probably be
better than player two so your posterior
after the fact that player
one wind from winds of in the game
against the player two is that the
distribution of player one shifts a
little bit to the right and the
distribution of player two shifts a
little bit to the left if in fact player
2 wins then of course it's vice-versa
the distribution of player 1 shifts a
little bit to the left and the
distribution of player 2 shifts a little
bit to the right now suppose that player
1 is very good we already know that and
player 2 is new so we don't know it's
gone now
if player 1 wins well of course we
expected that nothing change in our
knowledge we still don't know we already
expected player 2 to lose so we still
don't know anything of the skill of
player 2 and we already expected player
1 to win so we it does not change our
knowledge but in fact if the new player
player 2 wins in a game against the very
good player 1 then we know it must be
fairly good like it says here so if you
want to use this you can just install
the 2 scale package it's fairly easy and
but using it just goes like this you can
make a 2 skill rating and any true skill
rating starts with a default score of 25
and then well if you you can have them
play a game so for example here you can
see the player a and B before head
ratings of 25 and after once player a 1
it has a rating of 29 versus 24 player B
we can do it vice-versa
or we can keep playing games after this
so if player a wins again then it skill
increases a little bit more but not so
much because we already knew it was
better than B and the skill B decreases
a little bit more of course then if
player B wins then it makes a big leap
because we thought
before the player a was better what's
nice is that two skill can handle also
handle multiple players in a tie that
means in the game of Risk if we have
only one winner then player three
through four I know tie or losers so
using this we can evaluate players of
risk we can just have them play random
games between each other have true skill
maker ranking and then in the end we
have if we have a hundred players we can
just take the top ten now we just still
need a player that plays risk and a
genetic risk player and so I said before
the player needs to implement reinforce
attack fortify and turning cards and of
course we need a player that we can we
can we must be able to mutate the player
a little bit and combine it later so
first of all let's think of how to pick
a move easiest way is just to create a
list of all possible moves ranked these
moves based on some criteria and then
pick the top ranked move for example if
we want to place a reinforcement then
but as far as criteria we could for
example define some territory ratio so
for every territory we would calculate
the number of hostile territories around
it divided by the total number of
territories around it and we could also
define some criteria mission whether or
not the this territory is relevant for
the mission of the player so for example
if your mission is to conquer Africa
and the territory is in Africa then yes
is relevant so for example suppose we
have we own six territories we must play
must place a reinforcement and we can
calculate this territory ratio and this
mission criteria and then we define a
reinforcement rank which is basically
the territory
ratio times some weight plus this
mission criteria times the weight and
suppose we set these weights to 1 and 2
respectively
then we can calculate this reinforcement
rank for each of the territories and
here we see that reinforcement rank for
territory 80 is the highest so we pick
we placed our new army on territory 18
so how do we pay the weights of course
we do that with a genetic algorithm so
we initialize these players with random
weights which play many many games we
drop the bad players we combine and
mutate the good players to great to
create new ones and then we repeat so
for example if you go then look at the
territory ratio so for this territory
ratio we have this territory ratio wait
and then we initialize here in the top
left graph you see the initialized rate
so we are here we have a couple of
hundreds of players and each of these
players are red have a random weights
between minus 25 and 25 and then after
one iteration of playing so we haven't
let these hundreds of players all play
games and we have them we rank them
using trueskill and then we take the
best players and which so we drop the
bad ones we take the best players
combined and mutate them such that we
again have as many players as we started
at then that's what we look at at
iteration 1 at the top right and we
already see that players with a higher
weight here do much better so we see
that we are left with well in general on
average a higher weight now after it
took 10 iterations we get to the bottom
left block and we see that basically
only players with a positive territory
weight elect and then after iteration 48
all centers around 15 or so
but so what does it mean to have a
territory weight of 50 or 15 well of
course you have to normalize this
against something so that's why for
example for the mission weight I
normalize this I I say it can only be
either minus 1 0 or plus 1 so this means
in this case that the number of
territories around a territory that you
place your army on is 15 times more
important than whether or not the
territory is relevant for your mission
of course this makes sense because
you're not going to place any armies on
a territory that it doesn't have any
hostile territories around it but also
in general just if you have more
territories than you're more likely to
win and then in the end if you if you do
well in combat and ignore your mission
in the end if you have all territories
then you won anyway so I define these
five criteria for the reinforcements
first of all do I get a bonus it is this
territory part of a complete continent
that I own and do I get a bonus for this
continent secondly similar but if I not
do not own the full continent
then there's the mission value then
there's the army advantage of the number
of hostile armies around this territory
four versus the total number of armies
around it and the territory advantage
the territory ratio that I talked before
so this looked like this um first you
start with a random distribution after
one iteration it goes a little bit to
the middle and then after 40 iterations
you see that is actually it goes
negative that means that you better not
place any armies near very large hostile
troops that make sense so for the direct
bonus we also see that this goes to a
negative very negative value and also
that makes sense
because so the direct bonus means that a
territory is part of a continent that
you fully own that means that probably
no one is near there so you shouldn't
place our mr. so this to me this means
that the algorithm is doing well in ship
so I've always also defined all these
criteria for attack moves and for
fortification moves and then in the end
this is what it looks like we have in
the end 25 waves that after 40
iterations have a certain distribution
so that's it are we done well or no
these waves as you can see these
distributions they don't show only very
sharp peaks in the end you would expect
them to I guess but these 40 iterations
of running this algorithm took a couple
of weeks on my laptop and then I decided
I needed it back for work so if anyone
wants to know what it looks after a
hundred iterations please just take my
code and keep running and then I'm very
interested in the results also of course
right now
I use these weights and these are these
allow only linear combinations of the
all these ways of all the criteria and I
guess that their muscles have been
nonlinear effect here also players do
not look ahead to actually quote them
and they definitely not adapt to their
permit so in conclusion and I think I'm
done early so that I'm by now not in
between you and lunch anymore
we can play risk invited I've made a
genetic representation of a risk player
and I've used the genetic algorithm to
find better players I actually I took
one of the I took the best player from
iteration forty and played a game
against it it took me about six hours
typing in which move I was going to make
and I lost so n is one it's a good
player if you want to have a look at the
code or more information just go to our
blog you can find it right there all the
code is shared so please please improve
Thanks
[Applause]